the other day I was exploring options
for a go wide Beatdown deck so naturally
I was on the Eda treack pages of TSI and
tavar and on those pages I found
something that bothered me on both Pages
60% of decks run
cultivate now obviously edrek has some
inherent flaws that get further
compounded through users of the website
it would be cool if somebody made a
video about that or something but still
60% with a commander that's low Mana
enough not to re boost out by the ramp
part and who draws enough cards not to
need the tacked on land to hand you
could spend that three mana on literally
anything else there's also some
questionable draw run in these decks
whose Commander is an insanely powerful
draw spell so what
gives well I think this ties into the
culture of hailing certain cards as must
plays one that exists both online and in
IRL circles this sort of effect has
likely always been somewhat the case
among various Circles of magic gaing
since it's a social game game with an
established Community but EDH is
especially vulnerable to cycles of
overhype about particular cards this is
because it's an even more social format
than the Baseline due to having four
players and also the fact that it's
Singleton in 100 cards means that
there's kind of a lot of room for fluff
in decks and it'll take longer for
players to identify a mediocre card than
it would in a 60 card format there will
be the cards that truly should be added
to most decks on the basis of power soul
ring counter Spell mystic remor
and you can go check out my budget cards
video if you want my Saucy Saucy
opinions about them but there will also
be cards that are regarded in the same
lens but which truly don't belong in all
or even most decks and I want to focus
on a specific category of cards among
these Mana ramp
spells first a quick overview ramp makes
your amount of Mana go up typically
permanently baring interaction from your
opponents it's n ubiquitous in EDH due
to the slow speed of the format with the
first and second most played non-land
cards in the format both being ramp
spells and don't get me wrong ramp is
fantastic and there are lots of great
ramp spells out there but as you can
probably guess by the first couple
minutes of this video I have opinions
about some of them specifically I think
people tend to gravitate towards certain
ones that are considered Staples even
when there are other options that are
much better suited to their deck so
treat this video as a guide how to stop
jaming cultivate into every deck and
figure out what your deck actually wants
instead
hopefully there's plenty of nuance to be
gleaned here but this is a video
principally stemming for me getting
upset spaghetti about cultivate so let's
talk about that first cultivate along
with his twin kodam reach is a rampant
growth that costs an extra mana and has
a lay of the land attached it's a
straightforward formula with some clear
appeal in a slow format and evidently
Wizards agreed in 2011 it's in all three
Green precons in the first EDH set this
alone likely contributed to the card's
popularity and honestly the card is
right at home in these decks three color
decks with questionable Mana bases and a
healthy spattering of seven to n Mana
cards when you play cultivate you're
actively choosing an extra land to hand
rather than the speed of a two Mana ramp
spell and this is absolutely a trade-off
that some decks want the more colors you
play the more that extra land will
matter and color fixing might be a
valuable goal on its own right if you're
running a lot of colors with not a lot
of budget if you're playing Five color
and you have any three colors of Mana
that include green a turn three
cultivate sets you up for a turn four
with a Mana of each color available
that's a great deal this usefulness as a
setup piece is most obvious in a
five-color deck but the same logic also
works in decks with fewer colors as a
general principle cultivate is best
geared toward decks looking for a
pivotal five or six Mana turn this
brings me to a major consideration when
picking out ramp Mana curve a lot of
decks will have one or more major Mana
value numbers that they care about and
your ramp package should be formulated
to fit this
my gissa deck wants to play gissa on
turn two wherever possible followed up
with more ramp spells so if we look at a
graph of the Mana value of the deck's
ramp spells it's big spikes on one and
four mana and a smaller Spike on seven
because the deck is a disgusting greed
pile there are only a few two or three
cost ramp spells since the deck prefers
to skip two mana and play gliss on three
mana and the ramp spells of these costs
that are in the deck either create
untapped lands or have flexible Mana
costs when you're adding a ramp spell to
a deck you should be asking what is this
ramping toward wanting more lands in
general isn't necessarily the wrong
answer but if the most important Mana
value you're pushing toward is four you
shouldn't run a bunch of three Mana ramp
spells this is part of what prompts my
eyebrow raising when I see 60% of tosy
decks running the card it doesn't ramp
into the commander it takes up a Mana
slot that could have gone to a card
drawing beater and the commander itself
encourages volume of creatures rather
than size this means you probably don't
want that many many cards on fire six
Mana other than I don't know Mr
squirrels the commander also draws you a
ton of cards and if your deck has 33
forests each of those draws has a
healthy one-third chance of getting you
the exact land you want you're playing a
monocolor deck and if you play cultivate
you're effectively overpaying for ramp
that gives you an upside that you don't
need I find cultivate questionable in
tavar for similar reasons two colors is
still few enough that the color fixing
probably isn't necessary and werewolf's
top end consists of like a handful of
five and six drops rampid growth is
almost certainly better but I'm not sure
I'd even go for that over a two drop
beater that can draw you some
cards card type is another consideration
with regard to ramp since artifacts and
especially creatures will die to removal
and board wipes but land destruction is
much less common however dorks and rocks
are often more efficiently costed than
cards that grab lands so there are
trade-offs to be had they all have their
place but the places tend to be
different obviously for non- green decks
bless their hearts you're mostly stuck
with rocks but that doesn't necessarily
mean green decks will never want rocks
single green dorks tend to be the most
Mana efficient ramp option at lower
budgets so I tend to go for them in any
Deck with a three CMC slot is important
but the 2 CMC slot is unimportant my
gissa deck and my Maria deck both have
three Mana commanders that they try to
land on curve but glissa runs dorks
because it has very few two Mana plays
and Mario runs rocks because the one and
two Mana slots are very important for
the deck in a third one of my green
decks scape shift is a key piece of the
deck so the deck runs mostly land
grabbing spells in its ramp Suite even
though they're slower than single green
dorks long story short different decks
will want different things and these are
just a handful of examples of what I
ended up on with my green
decks a final consideration when
considering ramp cards is the net Mana
cost versus The Upfront Mana cost for
something like rampant growth or
cultivate these values are identical
since since they don't immediately offer
more Mana but some spells give you
untapped lands for example skysc claim
has an upfront cost of four but a net
cost of two if you grab forests that end
are untapped two ramp spells that I
generally prefer to cultivate in two
color decks are Harrow and grow From the
Ashes as they grab untapped lands and
thereby allow for more flexible turns
than a card that grabs tapped lands if
we look at Mana rocks most theoretically
offer Mana immediately but in practice
that can differ by when they're played
in what de is playing them signets can
be a net Mana cost of one after turn two
if the symbols line up but on two Mana
they can't do much else similarly
colorless tapping rocks like mindstone
add Mana immediately if you have a place
to put one colorless Mana but if you
don't they're just the sticker
cost I like to think I've offered a
little toolbox here in picking out the
most appropriate ramp and as a final
point I'll address an important question
I've been skirting around so far that
being how much ramp a deck should run
this question honestly depends on so
many factors that I'd feel irresponsible
offering a straightforward answer or
even a framewor the best way to tell the
right amount of ramp for your deck is
well to play it and see if it feels like
it has the right amount of ramp if
you're ramping to a particular value
does the deck succeed it that
consistently does it do so too well
eating up deck space and leaving you
with awkward spare mana on a lot of
turns there are also differences in the
size of Mana ramp spell so if you find
yourself drawing too many ramp spells
but want the same ramp capability you
can cut some small ones for a bigger one
or two conversely you can do the
opposite maneuver if your opening hands
seem consistently loaded with expensive
ramp spells you can't get to quickly
enough there may very well be strong
ramp spells Elvish Mystic Nature's lore
thought vessel that don't end up being
quite what your deck wants and this is
okay the best ramp solution isn't going
to be one size fits all at the end of
the day what I'm trying to say here is
simply that you should look at your
deck's ramp
critically I think when it comes to the
traditionally simpler parts of an EDH
deck the lands the removal the ramp a
lot of people have the idea that they
can kind of gloss over these things and
focus their efforts on the juicy
synergies that comprise the spiritual
core of the deck but these parts are
what lets the core of the deck do its
thing smoothly so taking a critical eye
toward them will likely improve your
deck more than you
think